manifestement depuis de nombreuses
années l'attitude adoptée à paris par
tous les gouvernements était de parler
le moins souvent possible de mayotte et
de son avenir
cela ne voulait pas dire que dans les
cabinet des ministères concernés à
l'elysée on ne cherchait pas des
formules pour trouver une solution
équitable à cette question mais le
problème n'est pas simple depuis qu'il a
été posé en février 1976 lorsque les
mahorais se sont prononcés par un
référendum local pour leur rattachement
à la france
six mois auparavant le président mohamed
abd allah avait proclamé unilatéralement
l'indépendance des comores le statut de
collectivité territoriale accordé à
mayotte à cette époque est prorogée pour
cinq ans par l'assemblée nationale en
1979 vient donc à expiration à la fin de
cette année
comment concilier d'une part le désir
maintes fois exprimée depuis par les
mahorais de rester français et d'autre
part les voeux émis régulièrement par
l'onu et l'organisation de l'unité
africaine de replacer au plus vite
mayotte dans l'ensemble comorien la
république fédérale islamique des
comores fait pression d'ailleurs dans ce
sens actuellement le gouvernement
français agit en faveur d'un
rapprochement dans les domaines
économiques techniques et culturelles
entre mayotte et les comores